[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando se nace el roble difícilmente los
vendavales nos doblegan hoy les
compartiré algunas de las experiencias
que me han llevado a tener un espíritu
un tanto inquebrantable por decirlo de
alguna manera al hacer mis ojos no
funcionaban del todo bien
y bueno empezamos a caminar este camino
de hospitales y residencia no para ver
si podían revertir la naturaleza de mis
ojos sin embargo la biología tuvo la
última palabra y bueno decidió que
después de 30 cirugías
lo poco que yo veía ya no ya no debería
de funcionar no entonces bueno desde
hace algunos años casi 24 soy una
persona totalmente ciega
y bueno empiezo este camino de ver tu
vida a través de lo que pareciera para
muchos oscuridad eso no una vida quizás
en el abismo no y casualmente me
sorprendo que el tener estos retos que
la ceguera me ponía enfrente empecé ya
un poco
a tomar las ruinas de mi vida si al no
permitir que las circunstancias decidan
por mí sino que yo pueda tomar mis
propias decisiones a partir de ellas
y así caminando esté mi camino bueno me
encuentro con personas que tienen
sentimientos nobles pero actitudes
equivocadas y hay tres eventos en
particular que empiezan como a definir
un poco hacia dónde quiero ir y por qué
quiero ir allá una es cuando yo de niña
sufrió un accidente de menos 12 años en
un accidente casero y entonces esto
acentúa un poco más de discapacidad
visual y hace que mi oftalmólogo le diga
a mis padres que no deben invertir en mi
educación porque sería perder el tiempo
y el dinero ya que una persona como yo
no va a servir ni siquiera para otra
bióloga o sea para limpiar pisos o no y
entonces mis padres afortunadamente no
hacen caso de esto y empieza aquí mi
tema de rehabilitación mi tema de
e ir a hacer hacia estudios y bueno esto
permite que yo hoy en día tenga muchos
logros no solamente académicos sino
también personales
también volteó a ver por el otro lado la
parte de la educación si cuando yo era
niña le decían a mis padres tu hija debe
estar en un entorno especial a donde no
hay niños con lentes de host de verdad
lentes de botella de cuando de botella y
que tienen ojitos saltarines no entonces
tu hija tiene que estar fuera de este
entorno aún teniendo materia gris
suficiente para estar ninguna escuela
regular de cualquier criatura de seis
años
cuando pasa muchos años
entró a estudiar un posgrado y me dicen
sabes que fíjate que necesitamos que te
des de baja porque la universidad está
preparada para atender alguien como tú
invitamos a que regresen años más tarde
y yo le decía perdón en serio es en
serio que esto se pasando en pleno siglo
21 nuevo con tantas avances que hoy en
día hoy en día existen y me decían sí sí
porque no estamos preparados y yo le
decía y estaba preparada para vivir con
unas realidades que quizás nunca nadie
me explicó que tenía que vivir no y lo
he hecho y bueno me di cuenta que iba a
tener yo profesores
y misioneros y mercenarios no esos que
están ahí por vocación y los que están
nada más porque no les quedó de otra ser
profesores y que todavía tenemos que
avanzar muchísimo en el tema de los
derechos de la educación que teníamos
que trabajar porque
estos profesores que trataban iguales a
los desiguales perpetuando la
desigualdad pues fueron cada vez siendo
tratados por nosotros por el desafío que
era que nosotros existiéramos en su
entorno y que existiera moss de la mejor
manera tenemos dignidad no bueno y así
caminando caminando
me voy encontrando con otras personas
qué
nos ven como algo raro no como te
atreves tú a intentar pertenecer a una
comunidad que no es como tú no y
entonces me doy cuenta que muchos ven
que nuestra lucha por querer tener una
vida digna tiene equidad van viéndonos
como si quisiéramos tener privilegios
como los que tiene la casa de windsor o
la casa de los borbones
y bueno dices a ver qué pasa aquí qué es
lo que está pasando tu reto mayor no
está en lo que tu ceguera representa o
en la limitante que turan atp da sino en
aquello que tu entorno representa
representa un reto que te dejen de poner
tantas barreras
en el transporte público no en el centro
comercial en los hospitales en donde
quiera es tu existir no no desde tus
limitantes sino de tus habilidades sí y
aquí es cuando yo llego a la conclusión
que nos puede faltar la vista pero no la
visión no la visión de la realidad que
nos toca vivir y bueno es cuando yo
volteó a ver a los que me precedieron no
y digo ahí estamos luchando por nuestros
derechos desde hace muchos años les hace
muchos siglos pero hemos ganado hemos
ganado en el sentido de que hoy por hoy
al niño que nace con una malformación no
sea el de mata desde la institución si
hoy por hoy a una a una persona que
tiene una discapacidad no se le ve como
un castigo divino como lo hacía la
religión en la edad media no y hoy por
hoy también ya no se nos aísla en
centros
especiales como lo hacía el modelo
médico rehabilitatorio pero tenemos el
reto de alcanzar una sociedad de
derechos
que no solamente nos hable de que
estamos en donde estamos parados sino
hacia donde también queremos ir y
también es un tema de obligaciones bueno
pasando a otro a un punto final yo les
quiero hablar un poquito de la relación
que tengo con aquellos que se hacen
llamar los amigos del hombre verdad que
aquí tengo una boca
desde niña los perros a mí me enseñaron
el valor de la amistad de la fraternidad
porque fueron los únicos que jamás me
rechazaron si fueron los únicos que
jamás primero vieron mi situación de
personas con discapacidad visual y luego
me vieron a mí
o sea primero vieron quién era yo y
luego vieron lo que yo no tenía bueno
los perros guías desde hace 21 años han
sido un reto muy particular de mi vida
porque llega mi primer perro guía el 21
de enero de 1998 todo es mejor perfecto
enero miércoles
no y llegan muchos retos conmigo porque
yo no sabía que tanto desconocimiento
había de un perro guía en el entorno
social
yo sabía que amaba a los perros pero no
sabía como los demás lo veían no y bueno
y vos para mí no sólo representa a ser
mi aliado sino también un poco mi
corazón porque con él
confrontó momentos agrasar osos
sorprendo sos amorosos y
me llegue mucho hasta la frase de ortega
y gasset que decía que yo soy yo y mis
circunstancias yo les puedo decir que
pues yo puedo decir que soy yo y mi
perro guía boca no
porque porque voy me permite hoy en día
ver muchas veces la razón y la sinrazón
del otro si la razón mía y la sinrazón
del otro cuando los niegan el acceso y
niegan la posibilidad de existir como un
binomio como un equipo de trabajo no
y bueno esto me permite a mí reinventar
mi cada momento cada instante y hoy
estamos haciendo una organización civil
en donde pretendemos precisamente
visibilizar pues todo el trabajo que los
perros asistencia hacen para aquella
persona que le da independencia que le
da bienestar no solamente a mí pero me
da compañía me da en este caso la
posibilidad de ver a través sus ojos y
bueno llegó a la conclusión también de
que es imposible que yo obligue al otro
a cambiar pero sí está en mis manos el
que el otro no me cambia a mí que no me
convierte en una marioneta sin sueños sí
y es por ello que les puedo decir que
este espíritu inquebrantable que me ha
caracterizado pues va a seguir adelante
no iba a seguir invitando a quien quiera
sumarse pues a luchar por el respeto de
la dignidad de la diferencia si es
importante que nos veamos como una
colectividad humana que pueda ser tan
tan fuerte como el más sólido de los
robles
muchas gracias
para nosotros